let's talk about where wokeness brings
us and evolutionary biology i think will
be interesting for this next
conversation uh we have a story from
daily mail
trans-upend swimmer leah thomas
complains about loss of muscle and
strength through hormone treatment and
says she's nowhere close to her previous
vest says competing on women's team is
fair now i want to say this outright
because i think it's important and i
think it's something you'll typically
hear from many of the you know
post-liberal disaffected liberals or
whatever and even many conservatives
although not all of them
i i think people should be able to be
happy and free and not disparaged for
you know whatever individual life
choices they want to make so it's not
harming others
this is the instance where
the transgender sport
issue actually does start causing you
know a degree of harm to others so if
those aren't familiar this is about a a
a person who's biologically male who is
transitioning to be a trans woman named
leah thomas who just broke a record in
you know a swimming competition and
defeated the next runner-up by over 38
seconds
which for people who understand
something if you've ever watched like
michael phelps the olympics that is not
just winning that is like just totally
outclassing and just absolutely
demolishing
everyone else
now there's there's a lot of people a
lot of people are bringing this up
in an interview with outkick a sports
website an unnamed athlete from i
believe this is um
what they say you pen
noted that while thomas is already
breaking school and meet records she
soon may she soon may be shattering
world records there's a few things we
can we can i can say here just to get
started
if you know the left if if their
ideology wins then i think the simple
argument is we as humans have created
these rules for these sporting events
and if we decide to change them then
they change but that ultimately means
there will be no women's sports
or i should say there will be no sports
exclusive to females to use you know
their their their language
or
we uh i suppose that actually i
shouldn't say or that's it that's
literally the outcome if we head in that
direction otherwise we have to say
outright there will be male and female
distinct divisions but uh you mentioned
you're an evolutionary biologist so i
suppose
that's my background i haven't been
doing i haven't done it for 20 years you
know oh yeah but you know you've got uh
some some context to add in this into
this conversation i suppose yeah
well okay i mean
i
i don't know what else i can say i mean
there's there's there there are very
very clear
i mean this is this is just the
biologist's perspective i think right
there's for just very clear biological
differences between men and women that
you can't
get rid of using hormone therapy or
frankly surgery or anything they're
they're they're foundational differences
and i mean and this i say this with the
greatest respect for people who are men
that want to be women and you know i
leave them to doing with to doing that
be free be free but this also means you
have to we have to reconcile other
people's rights as well absolutely and i
mean like this this sort of thing right
just on the face of it it it's is it
unsayable that they won because they're
physically male
right someone pulled up the am i is that
okay to say so yes that's
what other explanation is there or are
we supposed to believe that somehow this
isn't a factor i mean what they'll what
they'll end up saying is no not because
they're male their genitals had nothing
to do with this it has to do with just
being taller and having longer arms
which is because
which is a tendency towards you know
being male so the way i the way i framed
it on twitter is just look if the
argument is that from the left that
trans women are women
then as far and they say like literally
like indistinguishable well then it's
quite simple
this uh transgender swimmer has proven
women can swim as fast as men true and
that would mean that all the other women
who lost over 38 seconds are just not
trying hard enough
now actually i'll i i'll be reasonable
on this one to a certain degree i
actually believe
that there is a lack of competition in
in some women's sports because there is
a lower level of direct competition so
i've actually seen this in skateboarding
where there there are certain female
skaters i know who are insanely good at
skating and when i watch them compete to
compete like relaxed like they're not
going to push themselves too hard
because they don't have to and it keeps
everything kind of down so one of the
responses i got to this was well this
actually will drive biological females
to push harder and actually break those
records you know but my response to that
is is it going to matter if the record's
already broken by a trans woman and then
they'll never get anywhere near close to
it
somebody pulled up the uh time that this
uh this trans woman the the swimming
swimming times by like different races
and found they were only off by a few
seconds even after a year of of of
transition in which case
yeah it seems like they're still
competing at the male level which
apparently they were really good at in
the first place i don't know is this a
tired subject because we know it it
keeps happening no it's insane
completely unfair uh there should be a
trans division yes
if you have a kid that fails fourth
grade ten times you don't have him
compete with fourth graders when he's
18. come on and and there's a number of
well frankly feminists that are calling
this out because it's it's destroying
the terms
yeah right that was a really good point
though
if there's if there's somebody who's you
know 13 and they're in eighth grade and
they get held back three years and now
they're 16 and i've seen this i have
seen people have been held back three
years you know
now six 13 year old 16 year old is a big
difference and you're gonna you're gonna
make them play basketball against each
other you shouldn't
yeah so i mean it gets to a point where
he's just
mechanically
the sport doesn't function if you if you
imbalance it mechanically with with
artists or or performers that are too
strong or weak we were talking to uh we
had jack murphy on we we have him on
every other wednesday but we had him
here a while ago
and we and he was talking about how his
kids you know want to be you want they
want to they're athletes and they want
to be at the highest level and and he
was talking about you know his daughter
or whatever and i was just like
i mean the future of the olympics is
going to be uh trans women and i'm not
saying it'd be disrespectful to anybody
i mean i think it's just
an objective fact this uh this this this
young woman from upenn who spoke out
said
the ag the aggravated teammate also
claimed swimmers have discussed their
frustrations with their coach mike
schnur but he quote just really likes
winning i mean if you're somebody who
wants to see your your team winning if
you get compensation based on how well
you do they're going to be like don't no
don't care we're going to win
so i suspect what's probably going to
happen is we're going to have men's
divisions and we're gonna have subpar
men's divisions uh i suspect that will
be the case because um i feel like the
men who aren't quite as good are gonna
wanna go into trans women's divisions or
into the women's division because it's
gonna be easy i don't think that you
don't think that i do not believe
they're going to be men who are like
i'll take chemicals and alter my entire
life just so i can try and get a career
in a sport i do think there are going to
be guys um who are really who are
moderately good
and eventually want to transition and
then find themselves dominating the
competition
i i think it's a leap a lot of people
have made that argument that men will
chemically castrate themselves to win
basketball i'm like that's nuts
i don't believe that for a second i do
believe there are going to be males who
are trans who are good at sports or at
least you know moderately good or even
leaning on the bad side but still may be
ranking and then when they transition
that'll put them at the higher bracket
of the women's division and i believe
for a lot of reasons that would be
unfair to biological i could see a
psycho that wanted to win so bad that
they just devastate their body
transition it join another league with
this ripped male body into a female
league i mean south park had an episode
about that futurama i was i was eating
dinner the other day and feature there's
a futurama episode where bender gets a
robot sex change so
he he competes in the robot olympics as
a
he's male in the women's division and
then wins all the gold medals and then
in order to pass gender testing gets you
know a robot sex change or whatever and
what the interesting thing is this show
i think was made in the early 2000s
all of the characters said it's
disgusting they said it was gross and
disgusting that he was doing it and how
dare he but i think they're referring to
his cheating right you know but i i i
i think you know i'll agree with you
guys to a certain to a certain extent
that there may be really awful people oh
for sure who will exploit this the
bigger issue i see is that there have
been transgender athletes who have not
undergone any transition right there's
literally like a guy
and one day he just comes to the coach
and says you know you know i'm trans and
then they say okay you're in the whims
division now so that's why they're
trying to set standards for this
they're trying to quantify how it works
but it doesn't it doesn't but what can
the rules be i mean you there are the
rules that you have is your testosterone
level
i mean that that that's fascinating in
itself it can how can you do that what
kind you know
what this is this is this is a
fundamental human rights question in my
mind i mean these are i think the end
result is that there will fun there will
be functionally no
female sporting events right what about
if we have male female and then
genderless
i think that'll work yeah there someone
uh pointed out on twitter they're like
what do you call it then when men and
women on the same team i'm like they're
called mixed teams like they actually
bring this up apparently
there's like some commission or whatever
that oversees the racing or whatever
said that if this if the individual
who's trans is competing but hasn't been
a year on hormone therapy then the team
is classified as a mixed team and so
they'll race against a com a mixture of
males and females but this team is just
competing against you know straight
females
it's you know the craziest thing to me
is
there is a transgender scientist who's
also a marathon runner who actually did
a study in a report about male
testosterone about male muscular and
bone density benefits well after
transition who said that
yeah even a few years after transition
like the advantages persist this is a
trans athlete saying this
it's strange to me that there are
individuals who don't recognize
that it's unfair you know what i mean
like it's just what you would i mean
they did the study that's fantastic it's
also kind of what you would expect like
you would have to really do the study to
demonstrate that it's not the case right
but that it's fascinating i mean i don't
know i guess this is just another part
of
we have got two distinct
world views in this country
and this one is the left and the right
doesn't see it but all that matters i
guess where the kids go where where the
the next generation will be and i don't
know why why do we make women sports to
begin with was it so that women had a
like a place where they could compete
generally without having a guy like ian
did you know all the games did you know
that there's most sporting events
sporting leagues have no rule barring
women
at all
so uh women have tried out for the nfl
for instance but the closest they ever
get is to being a kicker and there have
been some women who are really really
good kickers but they're just not as
good as the male kids ncaa kickers male
1 football teams you have female kicker
i think that's happened in college yeah
there were well there was one woman and
then they lost and apparently the team
cried or something like that i'm i'm not
i'm not trying to be mean i think that's
actually happened yeah they they decided
they wanted to add the first female
kicker and they did and she flubbed
really bad i forgot what it's called
people tried saying it was a squib kick
because she kicked so short they were
like no it's a strategy but apparently
the team came out afterwards and they
were like this was brutal to us we've
worked so hard and now we're losing for
politics
so
there's nothing barring women from being
in male teams other than can they win
like can they when they try out do they
succeed so then we create a division
just for females but now we're having
the argument over what is it what does a
woman mean i mean wikipedia defines a
woman as a an adult human female but
activists are trying to change those
definitions and alter what these sports
are
did this girl score leah the girl from
uh score
her time her time was 38 seconds above
apparently it would have ranked her
second or third in the ncaa women's
championships just like
what does that mean like across the
country that was the second and third
highest that sounds that sounds like uh
national so some some guy transitions to
a female and then wins no no nc double a
opinion it is a male who is
transitioning to be a trans woman a
trans woman is different than a female
yes pardon my pardon my ignorance uh and
then and then ranks at the top that's
like complete insanity it's like use
some common sense if the floor is muddy
you know stop tracking mud on it and
clean it up this is a a guy that
transitioned to a well actually here
look at this the daily mail actually has
it they say uh how leah times stack up
against her best as a male swimmer in
the 200 meter free will before the
transition was one minute 39 seconds and
leah was one minute 41 seconds and the
nc double uh double a is 139.10
in the 500 meter free it was 4 minutes
18.
for leah it was four minutes 34 so
that's that's a bit down and the nc
double a is 424 and in the 600
650 meter free will got 14 minutes and
54. leah got 50 minutes 59 that's a
whole minute and the ncaa is 15 minutes
so
not like this individual's instantly
become the best but certainly one of
them i i don't know i i i think look i i
want to this this has been circulating
this is an old story not not this one
particular but the story that's
happening around someone who is male you
know we had joe rogan talk about this
almost 10 years ago i think it was with
fallon fox right
as far as i can tell if that's the case
it's happening it's done this is the
norm it's the combat it's happening the
combat sports is when it goes too far uh
if you have a man that transitions to a
female or a woman uh human female
whatever it's called i'm not sure if
transitions and then beats the hell out
of a guy or a girl
breaks her face like fallout i think
they didn't even know she was had
transition no one had told them that
fallon fox was that's that's now if you
want to do a non-combat sport and be
like hey i hit the ball farther than you
i used to be a guy but so what that's
dirty politics to me but
when you're hurting women when you're
when women are getting their faces
broken by people that used to be male
and have a lot of testosterone and
final final thought you know because i
think it's it's crazy that we've talked
about the story for so long and just
here it is it's normal now my final
thought i guess is like shouldn't they
just have an open division where anyone
can choose to compete thanks for
checking out this segment from the tim
cast irl podcast if you want to watch
live you can check out this channel
monday through friday at 8 pm now don't
forget to smash that like button
subscribe to this channel and if you
want more unfiltered and uncensored
content with all of these guests go to
timcast.com and become a member all of
these guests you know and love in
exclusive segments on our website where
we are unrestricted in what we talk
about so you'll definitely not want to
miss it thanks for hanging out we'll see
you all next time
you